uh
a snow leopard
he hasn't eaten
in days
this may be his last chance
[Music]
i'm two miles above sea level here
and it is brutal
cold
desolate
hard to breathe
but for some
this is home
[Music]
mountains are one of the most hostile
environments on our planet
now with the rise in global temperatures
life is even tougher
the relentless search for food
[Music]
intense competition
unpredictable weather
mountain animals are pushed to the edge
of existence
[Music]
the arctic circle
nowhere is the planet warming faster
spring has arrived here early
and that's bad news for the barnacle
geese the breed in these mountains
many nests have failed
but not this one
[Music]
three chicks
they're lucky to have made it
forced by the early spring
the parents rushed to their migration
they arrived exhausted
the female sat on the eggs for 25 days
she's lost 30
of her body weight
but for this family
the greatest challenge is still to come
the parents chose to nest on this
400-foot pinnacle
it's the only way to evade predators
just one problem
the grass they eat is a mile away
by the river
and barnacle geese can't feed their
young in the nest
if the chicks don't feed within 36 hours
they'll starve
and these chicks won't be able to fly
for another month
the parents are living proof
there is a solution
just not an easy one
dad
leads the way
but the chicks are instinctively bonded
to mum
where she goes
they follow
foreign
uh
incredibly
it survived
but it's stunned
and now dangerously exposed
[Music]
oh
[Music]
one chick gone
now hope rests with the other two
the back of the spire is a shorter drop
but it's much harder to avoid the rocks
for this chick
there will be no escape
the third
and last surviving chick
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
ah
the snow cushions the impact but offers
no grip
oh
only around 50
of chicks hatched on these cliffs
make it through the first month
with the seasons increasingly
unpredictable
fewer chicks will survive
[Music]
but this chick at least
has defied the odds
a changing climate is affecting life in
mountains across the world
late winter
the average temperature here is rising a
degree every decade
bad news
for a snow leopard
thick fur enables him to withstand
temperatures of minus 20 fahrenheit
but today
it's 66.
to find enough food he must patrol a
territory of 80 square miles
dry barren slopes don't support much
prey
it can be more than a week between meals
he must make a kill
or starve
[Applause]
sixteen thousand feet up
in the
a
himalayas
hungry snow leopard
his best opportunity in days is within
sight
blue sheep
in this heat
he can't run far
he needs to close the gap
[Music]
[Music]
his camouflage helps
but with so little cover
it's hard to get close enough
he ran too early
and it's too hot
to give chase
like all who live here
his fortunes
are linked to the mountain climate
[Music]
and even small changes can have dramatic
consequences
here in africa
rising temperatures are forcing mountain
life
ever higher
an army of gelada monkeys is gathering
they're all after one thing
but to find it
they must climb higher
and higher
their numbers grow to 1200 strong
one of the largest gatherings of monkeys
on the planet
at 10 000 feet
this
is what they're after
grass
it's almost all they eat
but so many monkeys in such a small area
means trouble
especially for this old man
[Music]
he needs a lot of energy to defend his
family
10 females
and 12 youngsters
but you don't get much from grass he has
to spend 10 hours a day feeding
and today he's gonna need all the energy
he can get
bachelor males
outcasts
forced to the edge of society
any one of them would be happy to take
down the old mail
and become the new family leader
to hold on to power
the old male must prove his strength
both to the bachelor's
and his females
he challenges them to chase
but no one dares to attack
his show of force
has worked
for now
the old male has little time to refuel
before the herd moves on
the bachelors are back
at this high altitude each confrontation
takes more energy
a relentless cycle of moving
feeding
and fighting
moving
feeding
fighting
by late afternoon the old male
is exhausted
[Music]
[Music]
the strongest bachelor
45 pounds of muscle
with energy to burn
wow
he's the most serious challenger yet
and the old man
knows it
two male gelada monkeys fight for
supremacy
a dominant male
and a younger bachelor
one against one
the bachelor is stronger
[Music]
the old male won't last much longer
at least
not alone
his females are loyal
they won't give up on their protector
yet
[Music]
this united force
is overwhelming
the old mail
is victorious
but it's tough at the top
[Music]
as a climate warms and the grass they
depend on retreats higher
their battle for survival will only
intensify
[Applause]
in the heat of mid-summer
mountain goats seek out cooler
temperatures on the high ridges
this female is a natural mountaineer
she can easily access the best grazing
even with a kid in tow
[Music]
but there's one thing they both need
that's far harder to reach
today they must leave the rich and
descend into the heat of the valley
for the little one
this is a dangerous journey
with the mercury hitting 100 degrees
fahrenheit
this is a hottest summer on record
[Music]
after a winter of heavy snow this means
more melt water than ever
mums made this journey before
but some rivers are at the highest level
in a hundred years
[Applause]
ah
their goal is in sight
just one more river to cross
but as the deepest
and widest yet
the current is too strong for little
legs
[Music]
and this is what they've risked their
lives for
assault flick
these goats crave sodium
an essential mineral lacking in their
mountain diet
summer in the mountains is short
harder times are coming
temperatures plummet
days shorter
winter is here
but the hunt for food must continue
heavy snow on higher ridges has forced
these ibex down into the valley
a cold winter can be a blessing for a
hungry snow leopard
he's less likely to overheat
but against the white
he's visible for miles
he must rely on stealth
not easy in such deep snow
[Music]
the distance was too great
the ibex too fast
now all the animals in the valley know
he's here
and he's burnt
precious energy
these are desperate times
if he's to see winter through
he may have to take bigger risks
throughout the mountains of the northern
hemisphere winter's grip is tightening
animals must make the most of any last
opportunity before conditions drive them
to take shelter
far above
planetary forces are on a collision
course
a river of air the jet stream flows
around the north pole
at its center sits a mass of cold arctic
air
but now a warming upper atmosphere is
slowing the jet stream
and the cold air can escape
by the time it hits the rockies it's
grown into a mega storm
freezing everything
in its path
in the depths of winter extreme storms
rage across canada and the usa
freezing temperatures wind speeds of up
to 150 miles per hour
now even the toughest animals are at
their limit of survival
[Applause]
so
the storms may have passed
but there is hidden danger in this
landscape
winter storms have buried this area of
british columbia under nearly 40 feet of
snow
but if temperatures rise above freezing
it can have lethal consequences
on the high ridges wind-driven snow has
created huge overhangs
some 25 feet thick
the longer the temperatures stay above
freezing
the more the snowpack weakens
do
soon tens of thousands of tons of snow
are traveling up to 80 miles an hour
as weather patterns change avalanches
across the world are growing bigger
the more erratic and severe mountain
winters become
the more victims they'll claim
but some are still succeeding in this
harsh world
golden eagles
live in almost every mountain range in
the northern hemisphere
they endure the alpine winter by using
the brutal conditions to their advantage
like all golden eagles this female has a
special sensory organ that detects
change in air pressure
allowing her to locate air currents
rising off ridges
with her seven foot wingspan
she can climb to over 11 000 feet
then
to get to the next peak
she folds her wings
and dives
with a top speed of 150 miles per hour
she's one of the fastest animals on the
planet
it looks effortless
and it needs to be
a golden eagle may cover a hundred miles
a day scouring the slopes for any
opportunity
[Music]
a flock of ravens is a good sign
during winter golden eagles are forced
to scavenge 90 percent of their food
if finding food is hard
keeping it
is even harder
a carcass like this attracts a lot of
attention
this male is powerful
and eagles don't share
another brutal storm
this could be the last chance to feed
for days
starvation is a serious threat
only a quarter of young eagles will
survive to reach maturity
will it be him
or her
attacking from the air gives her the
advantage
but her victory is short-lived
now both eagles may be fighting for
their lives
in the peaks of norway
two golden eagles are fighting for a
chance to feed
[Music]
both are desperate
the female stands her ground
for the male is not done
hey
[Music]
each eagle is armed with two-inch
talents
these fights can be deadly
[Music]
her kick was decisive
[Music]
what's left of the frozen flesh may be
just enough to keep her alive
but this harsh winter will drive others
to even greater extremes
this snow leopard's relent the search
for food continues
following the scent of prey has drawn
him to the edge of his territory
and into a steep ravine
blue sheep
the broken rock provides good cover
but this is difficult terrain
[Music]
now
he must let them
come to him
a 200 foot full
never letting go
[Music]
[Music]
finally the snow leopard can eat his
fill
[Music]
but success has come at huge cost
he's badly injured
for a hunter that lives by its agility
this could be fatal
[Music]
the challenges of survival up here at
altitude are so extreme that it seems
near impossible that anything can make
it
but the resilience of mountain animals
is near miraculous
incredibly
just three days later
we filmed the same snow leopard
back on its feet
hunting again
[Music]
it takes true grit to survive in these
desolate unforgiving landscapes but
somehow animals still manage to triumph
to find shelter
food
and perhaps most importantly
each other
[Music]
against all odds snow leopards are still
breeding here in the himalayas
they are living proof of mountain
animals amazing ability to succeed in a
changing world
their offspring will be the hope
for the future
[Music]
[Music]
you